In this video, we'll formerly introduced
the multi layer neural network.
We seen previously that there are
certain problems that a single artificial
neuron can not model.
Well, uh, because, uh,
it's a problem that which is saying
a classification setting that is not
linearly separable.
However,
however we've seen that
we can actually take a,
our input representation
and try to instead, uh,
transform it in some way by applying
some perhaps simple transformation like
applying he and in this case
here, the end function over, uh,
to transform version of the input to
obtain the new representation of our input
vector,
which is now linearly separable.
And if this,
the computation of this representation
can be made by artificial neurons,
then this is suggesting a more complicated
model for more complicated problems,
which would consistent first
repor first computing a set or a,
a number of artificial neurons that
will compute this new representation.
And then connecting those
neurons to an output neuron,
which would do the rest of the job and,
uh,
finished a computation of are
more complicated function.
And so this will be the
inspiration behind, uh,
the use and development of
multi layer neural networks.
So let's look at this idea more formally
in the case of a single hidden layer.
Uh, so, uh,
what we mean by the hidden layer is
the computation of this representation,
which will make the problem
more, uh, linearly separable.
And so in this single layer
neural network will, we'll have a,
the first part of the computation
which will compute the representation.
And then finally the computation
of our output unit, which will, uh,
perform the, um, the computation of
our, say, our binary classification.
The more formally when we're computing
the hidden layer, we will compute again,
a pre activation function.
And not in this hidden layer we see
here we might have several, uh, neurons,
not just a single neuron. And so, uh,
each of the IAF neuron,
which will I will call a
WHO's activation function,
the outfit activation will be h of X.
I will be connected to
all potential inputs.
And so the connection with between the,
uh,
I have hidden a neuron with the JF input
will be a contained in some matrix,
which we will call w and tickets
opponent in parenthesis one.
So this is to refer to the case where
we have just a single, a hidden layer.
So doubly one is the weight
Matrix, uh, for the same, uh,
the first hidden layer.
And similarly we will have biases and so
bias of the iff hidden unit will be B I
and uh,
uh,
the one here in the exponent is to
refer to the first hidden layer again.
So whenever we are computing
the pre activation,
we will actually have a
vector of reactivation, uh,
where the IFL element of that
vector will be the IFP, uh,
activation for the IMF neuron
and that a hidden layer.
And so for the I of effector,
sorry,
dif pre activation will get the IMF,
uh,
bias plus the weighted combination
of all inputs j and where x j will be
multiplied by its connection with the
of a neuron and a if we want to perform
this computation to want to perform
this computation for each hidden unit.
So in fact,
we can write it into matrix form to
obtain directly deep reactivation vector.
And, uh, this would only essentially
correspond to taking the vector x,
multiplying it by our matrix w one,
and then adding the whole vector
of biases B one. So indeed,
if we take x and multiply
it by W, um, we'll, uh,
we'll, we'll, we'll get
this, that for the iff role,
we'll get a term which corresponds to the
sum of all the elements over that role
of matrix w one multiplied by the
corresponding elements in the vector X.
Okay. So we see that this, and
this is actually equivalent,
uh, then to compute the
hidden layer activation, uh,
we simply apply our activation function
over all the elements in the vector.
So this, uh, here in my notation,
I'm assuming we are doing an element
wise application of the activation
function,
Jay,
that we've chosen chosen either the
sigmoid or the Tange or rectified,
linear and so on.
And then finally we get
an output activation,
which I will call or I will note
f of x by taking the hidden layer.
So this hidden layer, so does a
parenthesis missing missing here, a,
we'll call it h one of x again one,
because we have a single hidden layer.
So we'll take that vector of hidden units
and then we'll multiply it by double u
two,
which is going to be the vector of
activations between the output and all the
hidden units.
So w to y here is the weight of the
connection between the output unit and the
hidden units.
So we compute that,
then we add the bias of the opportunity
and then we will also have a uh,
activation function.
And I'm going to know that o
for output activation function.
And this is because we will typically
make different choices for the output
activation function. Then, uh,
for the hidden units in the neuron
network.
So, uh, if we want to do
binary classification,
we can just use as the output activation,
the sigmoid activation function.
And so this would correspond to the,
this means that at the output
we would get the probability of,
uh,
the input belonging to class one.
But if we have multiple classes, if I
have more than two classes, uh, then, uh,
what we'll need to do is
have multiple outputs.
And specifically we want to have
one output unit at the output layer,
uh, per class. And, uh,
now we'll still want to keep this idea
that our neural network will estimate the
a conditional probability.
So we'll like the output layer
to give us the probability of a,
the input belonging to each potential
class, which I note seats. So,
um,
see what a typically belong in one
up to a certain number of classes.
Capitol C. Okay. So if we had 10 classes,
then capitol c would be equal to 10 and a,
so we would have indexed
all of our classes, uh,
from one to capitol seat one to 10.
And so,
uh,
to get an output,
which corresponds to a valid
conditional probability.
What we'll use at as the output
activation function is what is called the
softmax activation function.
And what it takes is that what it does
is that it takes the pre activation and
it simply takes the exponential of all
M and elements of that reactivation
vector. So it's a vector now
because we have multiple classes.
So we have multiple, uh, output neurons.
And so we are multiple
reactivation, uh, values.
So the soft Max takes the exponential
of all of those numbers and then divides
each of these numbers by the
sum of the vector, by the,
some of the exponential of the pre
activation for all possible classes.
See, that's why we have this
some old receipt here. Okay.
So because we are normalizing our vector
like this because we're dividing by the
sum of the numerators here,
then we are guaranteed
that it will sum to one.
And uh, that's because we're
divided by the sun, the,
some of the numerators.
And also we are guaranteed that
it's going to be strictly positive.
And that's because the exponential of
any number is necessarily greater than
zero. So we will have a valid, uh,
probably the distribution, the numbers,
the probabilities are positive
and there's some two more.
And then if you want to
predict an actual class,
so if he get an input x and
one to actually assign it
to a particular class a,
then the natural thing to do is to use
the class with the highest estimated
probability. That is again, uh,
we just look at all the output units and
we output the class associated with the
upper cabinet that has the largest value.
Yeah.
And finally, uh, in the previous example,
we had only a single hidden layer,
but there's no reason for not using
multiple hidden layers. And, uh,
we will discuss in other videos,
uh, why we might want to do that.
But to get this generalization
to multiple hidden layers,
say l hidden layers,
uh,
we'll have now a activation function as,
sorry,
a p activation value at any hidden layer.
Kay.
So we'll call that a k of x.
And as this will just correspond
to the bias of that hidden layer.
Plus the Matrix of
connections for that key.
If hidden layer multiply by the activation
values at the previous hidden there.
So at the hidden they are k minus one.
And if we use a for our definition,
uh,
if we assume that h zero of x is just x,
so age zero would be the
zero with in an layer.
So this will correspond to the input
layer here in our definition then that
this,
uh,
correctly defines the pre
activation value at all.
Then there and then to get
the hidden layer activation.
So the output of the hidden
units at each hidden layer,
what we do is that we simply take,
apply again the activation function on
the reactivation of the curse finding
hidden there. And then to get
our output layer activation,
which corresponds to the
index of the layer cake, uh,
equal to l plus one where l is
the number of hidden layers.
Then, uh, what we could,
if we use these definitions here
for the activation function, uh,
so for the layer l plus one h l plus
four on the x is going to be again the
activation function.
Uh,
but pass through an activation
function for the case. Uh,
we have the, uh, output
layers. So the, uh, uh,
index alk plus one,
we'll use our ever,
not the g activation function,
but the output activation function
that we're noting. Oh, and, uh,
typically instead of using this for
the notation of the output layer, uh,
often referred to it instead as f of x,
which is to be the output
of the neural network.
Now if you're wondering why we say that
these layers here are hidden and this is
the output.
So this is the output for the obvious
reason that this is the actual value that
is you say by our classifier,
which is trying to classify some input.
And these are hidden because we don't
know what's the actual right value for
these hidden units. So the
neural network, uh, when we talk,
when we talk about learning and
the parameters of a neural network,
it will try to find what's the correct
behavior for these neurons here.
However, for the output, we know what's
the right answer. So we're normally,
we'll have some label data
and for some given input,
we will actually know which
output we want to see,
have it's value be the
biggest amongst all output.
So that's why these guys are actually,
these hidden units are actually hidden.
They're hidden in the sense that we don't
know what's the actual best value for
them to take for some given input.
We only know what value would like to see,
uh, for the output. If
we actually know, uh,
say in some data, if we actually know that
certain inputs are classified in some,
uh,
certain classes.